será llamado una burbuja olímpica de
ciclo cerrado y durante los juegos sólo
se permite el ingreso de atletas
entrenadores organizadores y voluntarios
la idea es evitar cualquier transmisión
de ccoo y 19 a la comunidad tan pronto
como llegan al aeropuerto los
participantes de los juegos serán
acompañados a las burbujas los trenes
que unen beijing con jiang qing y sand
ya que tienen vagones exclusivos para el
personal olímpico mientras que en las
guías hay un carril especial la policía
local advirtió a los conductores que no
ayuden a personas en peligro
si ves un accidente en el carril
olímpico mantén la distancia y no te
acerques que la semana pasada china
canceló los planes para vender al
público entradas para los eventos
olímpicos
la medida fue recibida con una mezcla de
frustración y comprensión
estoy feliz de que se lleva a cabo en
beijing estoy orgullosa pero lo veré en
la televisión
dentro de la burbuja donde ya comenzaron
los entrenamientos se aplican medidas
estrictas incluyendo mascarillas
faciales obligatorias controles de
temperatura y pruebas de pcr diarias una
vez en la zona los participantes no
podrán entrar y salir ni siquiera la
basura recogida durante los partidos
será retirada del recinto